قتل وقصف ودمار بعد 120 يوما من الحرب على
غزه نحن هنا في مدينه رفح جنوبيه القطاع
حيث كانت هذه المحافظه على موعد جديد مع
غارات جويه ادت الى ارتقاء عشرات
الفلسطينيين وتدمير عدد من المنازل هذا هو
واحد من هذه المنازل التي جرى قصفها من
قبل الطيران الحربي الاسرائيلي والحاق
الدمار الكبير بهذا المنزل ومنازل مجاوره
هذا ما تبقى من اثاث هذا المنزل بطبيعه
الحال دائما ما نعتاد على هذه النتيجه
الطبيعيه التي تعكس الوحشيه الاسرائيليه
وعنف الغارات الجويه والقذائف المسقطه من
قبل الطيران الحربي الاسرائيلي على هذه
المنازل ضمار وخراب كبير عدد كبير من
الشهداء والجرحى جلهم من الاطفال
والنساء وايضا ضمار كبير حتى في منازل
مجاوره هنا كما تشاهدون في هذا المشهد
قاعدين وما شي طلع ينام فوق وشي طلع ز
متجوز سنتين يا اخويا وكل واحد ولا ح ولا
واحده اللي عندها ست سبع تنفار ببلا جا
الصاروخ كله راح زي ما انت شايف ضمر شامل
جاري وجاري وبيت اللي غاد واللي هان واللي
هان كله دمر شامل ومش عارف لوقت ايش بد
نضلنا لهيك ننا لوقت ايش والله ما انا
عارف دمار شامل وهجره و هجرونا ورجعوه ل
100000 سنه وراء والله العظيم بنا سنتين
او ثلاثه لما ترجع الدنيا دنيا لما ترجع
يقدر يقفوا على رجليهم الناس حسبنا الله
ونعم الوكيل دمروا الشمال ودمروا خون دمبر
الدنيا كلها كل الدنيا شهداء وكل الدنيا
اطفال مع صغار مع كبار مع مال مع مع بني
ادمين مع بيوت مع كله دمار شامل هنا ايضا
وصلنا منزل اخر يبعد عن المنزل الاول فقط
عشرات الامتار وهنا ارتقى علق الاربعه من
الشهداء وهذا هو ركاب ايضا هذه البنايه
التي تم تدميرها واضح انها طبعا مكونه من
عده طوابق كما تشاهدون في هذا المشهد
نايمين لو بيجي القفال علينا غبره
وشالوني هم روحت عن دار
الهوبي
منهم ماس ومريم وعم
ابراهيم بس وعنده
الاء بالمستشفى مصاب وعبود مصب في المجت
في المجت بس هي هي اللي صار
صفونا معنا كنا نايمين ليش
قصفنا
كرى ودميه هذا ما تبقى لاطفال كانوا
يعيشون في هذا المنزل كيف لا وهم النسبه
الاكبر من بين ضحايا هذه الحرب هاني
الشاعر لقناه الجزيره مدينه رفح